laQuan Liam he's top
I think he's top like 30 or 40 in the
world over 2,700 very strong player I've
played them a couple times in classical
games and collegiate events lost both so
he's playing a green fouled
seems like some kind of theory I'm not a
specialist in anything related to the
green fella all I know is black usually
wants to play e5 at some points it's one
of the main pawn breaks I were in faith
with 200 that's thanks for the bits so
clearly with rook e8 he wants to play e5
he got c5 in things got traded and then
c6
okay so queens are staying on the board
this brings us to the current position
it's gonna be a fight I mean it looks
very balanced equal material
I think Greenfeld is a very good opening
to play to get like some imbalance
position where there's room to play for
a win against a weaker player I should
note in the first game the board four on
one team plays a put one on other teams
so this is the biggest rating
differential there's about 600 points
between these these two players and okay
we see that with this last move a five
lakh is going for some that's some
positional play on the Queen side and
White's still playing very quickly 94
attempting to trade bishops and simplify
I think at some point we'll see a for
like a for maybe right away maybe black
will take first and then play a four but
in a position like this black wants to
use a Queen side majority to at some
point probably get past pawn and then
use it to have some advantage
okay so AJ murasky asking if the actual
ratings are PDA ratings yeah I think
these are these are feeder ratings
I think chess comm for this for
protesting they changed the username and
the rating to match the person's like
feed a profile that would be my guess
and the ratings I use are from September
so I I think these are probably
September feed a ratings this is a first
first match protesting match of 2019 so
I am still learning kind of the ways of
what's going on it's been a while since
i've streamed on chess calm but good to
be back always a nice nice sort of
layout with a square board I guess
all boards are square but I like the
fact they put the name of the player
below the board ok good to see a lot of
people in the chats who is watching a
lot of people Bracken Dawson why is a
chess board difference as Abdo bends I
think I've answered that we are not on
me chess anymore
yack over brings up a good point that
laQuan liam recently lost to eleven year
old or twelve year old Christopher you I
think he's still 11 in the the bay area
chess tournament Christopher you had
just a monster event beating not only
laQuan Leon but also another Geum Peter
per Houska and he became the youngest
iron in US history which is huge 100
bits from sarony leo thanks for the bits
Sola calling Liam he's not invincible
except when I play him he's invincible
I've never beat him like even in
training games we were teammates for a
couple years at Webster and we would
sometimes play like blitz or have some
training like sparring sessions and just
crushes me every time
oh I forgot to change the stream title
let me do that right now
how do I do that
did I change it no I didn't change it my
dad okay I think that worked go back to
the chat chat okay it worked nice angel
agüero from the USA okay so the
positions evolving block did not go for
a four as I tried to predict 95 the f4
looks very weakening and Bishop g4 what
a move distracting the Queen from
defending b2 and the great thing about
this position III is just a major
weakness like it's kind of backwards
it's aligned with the Queen and the rook
not to mention f5 was also a threats I 5
still a threat so white plays that 5
brings us to the current position this
is looking really nice for black like
black just has amazing peace harmony
rooks in the center super solid King
side and I think White's weakened
himself when it really wasn't necessary
playing this f4 move just gives black of
very juicy targets on III and Queen e5
has a threat very simple threat of just
taking removing the night and then
everything was kind of falling apart for
for whites and if white takes and just
take back and still go for f5 f6 has
only other move that comes to mind that
just might takes f6
always nice to see how a super Geum like
just out plays a weaker opponent so g4
interesting try trying to maintain the
that fog but again like okay white is
weakening himself a bit further but what
to do for black I was singing Bishop h6
but that could maybe prompt g5 and black
would just like to build up more
pressure this is another exercise I
recommend especially when watching
strong players play live is just trying
to guess their moves can be a very
proactive way just to study chess Knight
f6 looks very reasonable
it's a move I would be a little hesitant
to play for black because it allows some
obstacle our Bishop position but I guess
if the light goes away from e4 then it's
easier to get to e3
okay so I'll try and answer some
questions in the chats so okay the title
update worked nice
elephants have bigger brains and any
other animal get to know I might play
with elephants or at these visits and
elephants within the next week it's
Thailand is a great place like there
there's some like elephant sanctuaries
where they rescue elephants and you can
come go and like feed them and bathe
them and take pictures with them hello -
Cetner Rob Oh Rob just discovered my
channel and devoured it okay home nice
to see I hope you devoured it in a good
way and a bad way
Oh Queen f3 okay so there's some action
I mean this bishop is currently pinned
to the pawn g5 but just pawn takes your
queen takes g5 what was g5 I was
thinking maybe something like h4 like h4
it would have been more interesting
because the bishops pinned and g5 is
hard to stop but g5 immediately I think
that's just a blunder and now black is
up a happy pawn this pawn still weak the
King sides open now if Queen stay on the
board then black has attacking potential
- opposite Clara bishops sometimes make
positions more sharp like h2 could be a
target okay trip d2 coming
it is 5:33 a.m. in Thailand it is
usually not a time that I'm awake for
but I really didn't want to miss the
first match of the protest League this
is a third season of the league last
year the windmills made the playoffs or
at least may like I think the round of
the round of 8 or round of 16 then we
lost to Minnesota but we have a very
strong team potential to go very far
hopefully at least make the live finals
in San Francisco so there's gonna be
matches every week for the next I think
there's at least 10 in total 8 to 10 in
total and then there's a few like
weekends like special event matches too
so I'm gonna try and do as much
commentary as possible during these
matches if I'm free I'm I'm streaming
them am i coaching again this year I
don't know what you're referring to
about coaching like just private lessons
or like coaching some teams hey it's a
donation $10 $10 saying something about
something greetings from Poland nice I
didn't catch the name though whoever
donated $10
thanks for the $10 and say hi in the
chats because I feel bad I didn't catch
the name yeah let me know where you guys
are from it's always interesting to see
like the diverse countries who are being
represented in the chats okay the name
is Damian well thank you Damian how does
the protest work asks majesticness 17
it's hard to like say entirely how it
works when I concise
statements but I'll try my best
essentially there are I mean I should
really know some more information
there's about 32 teams from around the
world each team has at least a few
grandmasters I think five out of the top
six players in the world are represented
including Fabiano and Wesley so playing
for the st. Louis Archbishop's and each
team is basically just a different city
and every week they play online matches
against against different teams in their
own kind of division and then the
highest-scoring teams will make the
playoffs and then the final four teams
of the playoffs will compete at a live
event in San Francisco and the top or
the winning team of the season gets
$20,000 I think second-place team gets
$10,000 so there are some nice prizes on
the line there's also weekly prizes for
like best game and I think best move
last year I played I only played one
match for the Webster windows and I had
a terrible showing I lost three games
and drew a game and thanks for the bits
Niall Homer 2,000 bits for being up so
really more like staying up so late I've
stayed up way too late
but I mean let's try and stay awake for
the next hour and a half at least anyway
I played last year and my one draw was
like a miracle draw the game ended in
stalemate because my opponent pre moved
something but he kind of fell into like
some funny trap and I up getting move of
the week for it and to get move of the
week I had to beat out Carlsen and Cara
Juana in a Twitter poll
as one of the best like victories of my
life beating them and a Twitter poll
ok so black is crashing through very
soon I think we're gonna see either
checkmate or resignation or Queen side
pawns being pushed we could switch over
and look at some of the other games
there are currently two other games
going on so we'll take a glance I just I
glanced at this position and just see
this massive gun on the e-file the
so-called Alekhine's gun and y'all homer
with a sub it's Neal as an open file not
sure what that means
okay Knights e8 with the clear intention
of bringing the knight to a happier
place
so this match is between iliyan is Nick
very strong GM was also on my team for a
couple years at Webster playing against
Alexander cats so I think I'm pretty
well known I am from the US I'm strong
player and even like GM's it can take
work to beat I can I am like this the
current position is equal material luck
has some poll Queen d2 is played to like
defend the rook enough times so maybe
the knight can move I'm actually curious
here why can't white just take that for
pawn Knight takes f4 I mean trade a
bunch of times on he won that's that's
not getting anywhere
yeah I'm actually confused here like why
is he giving away a four I probably
would have been inclined to play g5 I
mean there's some 94 Intermezzo 94
I mean maybe just night maybe ninety
four and then rook f6 maybe he
calculated some initiative so white
doesn't take the pawn Knight c3 safer
preventing that e4 also trying to
neutralize the e-file f3 will the move
seems like a sort of a positional
sacrifice bike just wants to destroy
White's pawn structure I'll you have
pawn to f3 there's Queen h4 and yeah the
King side is very weak if I plays g3
then this pawn just stays on f3 and it
looks kind of annoying it's a nice move
and he played it just so quickly
like sometimes I move like f3 you don't
really calculate you you just play
intuitively
and it puts the ball like in White's
court immediately and now he has to take
more time I'm trying to judge the risks
you know I would probably be inclined to
play g3 because it prevents Queen h4 but
he takes okay bold decision expecting
Queen h4 and I'm thinking the
combination of Queen h4 and Knight f5
because d4 is also a target
looking for other candidate moves for
for black
there's my that five immediately you
could play night of five immediately to
keep the H Foursquare open because maybe
the night wants to come to h4 and attack
the pong
there's also Queen f6 just hitting f3
pressurising d4 and Queen f6 looks
attractive
onie all is pronounced Nile
oh so it's Nile as an open file
oh okay I hear Stan this whoa okay so as
soon as I get distracted the physician
just drastically transforms so you did
play Queen h4 okay they trade in humans
d4 so it's still equal material but okay
blacks clearly better for multiple
reasons and structurally these pawns are
sad more active Queen and night for
black just better coordination two very
safe King and there's some attacking
potential like still this maneuver very
possible this is the type of situation
like if Queens are off the board then
white should be okay
actually blacks allowing a queen trade
just somewhat surprising so I would
think black wants to keep Queens on the
board cuz okay White's King is less safe
but the ending will still be pleasant
for black and maybe maybe there is no
we're good to go with the Queen like he
didn't want to give away the a7 pawn so
this is gonna be a grind
he's playing so quickly like Ilya is one
of these players he just he's know how
to describe it
he just doesn't calculate like he's just
he has so much underlying knowledge and
he has such good intuition that he's
able to blitz out moves just has a very
good feel for things it's actually
incredible this night could be no I'll
say trapped but could be stuck for a
little bit like the idea of King offs or
King f8 king east seven looks annoying
to deal with because night like
literally can't move back towards its
own territory like all these squares are
off guards and the only safe squares are
like moving deeper into box territory
but we might ceiling night be seven
nights e5 but blacks King is gonna
activate I wouldn't be surprised if
black just walks a king and white scheme
is just kind of stuck on the the King
side so I'm staying with this game the
Longley I'm game is still going on I'm
assuming he's gonna win very shortly
his opponents just playing either lost
position sarony Leo thanks for the bits
switch from chess bra guess you maybe
wanted a different Eric well thanks for
thanks for the support
c5 Wow
I mean c5 now this nights gonna be stuck
but it's a question can black start
targeting the pawn like black would
really like to get this knight to d3
where it can control before so I'm
wondering if this is a possible in
maneuver like Knight c2
the thing is though black has to watch
out for counter play so he plays B for
this nice prophylactic move preventing
white from playing before this is what
we call artificial isolation like this
pawn isn't technically isolated because
there's a pawn on a neighboring file but
it's basically isolated because white
can't never defend a c5 pawn with his
own pawn and now it seems like there's a
very clear plan again for black just to
lock up the King and white seems
paralyzed okay maybe the knight can
transfer itself but that doesn't really
do anything
so okay White's trying to walk up his
King at the cost of giving away the f3
pawn also White has 18 seconds left
forgot about time the gang goes back to
why Illya is like just so good at rapid
he really puts the point under pressure
in the position and timewise now we're
just seeing like just a nice positional
grind he doesn't doesn't care about
winning the F pawn his 96 will come at
some point but okay
King d5 first
and plans are falling left and right
Knight f6 is a an idea maybe H 5 H 5
looks nice
because then g6 is very hard for the
knight to attack at least quickly
do you have to be careful though like
sometimes these endings like in the
nights can be tricky have to watch out
for potential Forks
I mean he could also just take and then
later play h5 it's from Jacob Shore I
helped you so much in previous years at
NN Oh
nice to hear from you 100 bits thanks
for showing up on the stream for those
who don't know NN is the high school I
graduated from and I still I still do
some coaching for them too
I'm their official assistant coach for
this year even though I'm out of the
country for a few months
ok so somehow he won you won both F
bonds ok so you just walked up the
king's so deep yeah this this pawn can't
be stopped it's reasonable okay so
laQuan liam lon iliyan is nick wanna we
have one game going and I'm really sorry
to save I think our board 3 forfeited
I'm checking Facebook pretty sure our
board 3 forfeited more on that later
let's look at this game Joshua Gretzky
who's our new new recruit for us the
brother of Aaron gourbin ski two very
prominent chess players from the state
of Oregon unfortunately it looks like
Joshua's going down this game but going
down with the fights I mean so Thurman
is very strong GM like look at the
rating differential almost 700 points so
to be lasting this long as maybe some
there's some good thing about that and
in a team match like this sometimes it's
good if the weakest player gives the
strongest player some grief and then it
can sneak away their energy for later
games
ok so we'll leave it on this one very
little hope you never know nights can be
tricky now what's an M national master
yeah so national master title for urban
ski it's a title which isn't it's not a
feed a title it's a u.s. title
if you cross 2200 on the US rating
they'll mail you a certificate saying
you've earned the title of national
master I think it was the first title I
ever received or at least a first
certificate for a title that I've
received
so amazingly it's still a little bit
tricky because the Queen Queens active
and the Queen night combination is
usually better than the Queen Bishop
combination King g7 is a good move
though just purely preventive and yeah
the king is safe what to do
maybe Queen c7 hit the bishop hit pawn
which is defended by thanking f7 the
King f7 maybe go back and then try and
get some play
how do you enter an over the board
tournament if you have no feed a ranking
that's good question I actually don't
know the specifics I know like in
together feed a rating you need to play
over the board tournaments against other
feed a rated players so you basically
start off as unrated and when you play a
feed a event you get a feed a ID and
then I think you need to score one out
of three against feed a player's to get
an official rating I could be wrong on
that but I'm pretty sure that's how it
works
my first feed I reading was like very
high at least for my like level and age
at the time because I performed well in
my first feed a event I got a rating of
like twenty one hundred something when I
was 12 years old when I was twelve years
old I remember that actually because I
was babysitting like these younger chess
players when I was yeah when I was
twelve and then the parents were really
impressed that my feed a rating was over
2,100 my first job okay so 94 King G to
King safety first not looking good but
okay time is getting low 32 seconds for
black 19 seconds for whites
Queen z5 is pretty much lights out I
think we might see Queen eight shades
and just see to the Kings gonna find
safety like there's only a few checks
for whites or maybe I don't know he has
to worry about Queen takes h5 check g2
and blacks getting seriously low on time
but so is white there is a two second
increments yeah he's scared of Queen
takes h5 so just take the pot and give
it a check and just keep checking until
King g7 maybe Knight g4 I think you have
to go for it
it's not the move you want to play this
should be - Oh Bishop e2 Queen takes me
to with check please play this should be
- oh he's gonna see it there is also
Queen takes g5 IG for good try Oh still
Bishop b2 Queen takes B to because
there's counter play wow this is getting
close Queen d1 good move Queen III I
just have to hope the checks work out a
King g7 check on b7 good fight let's
keep checking
yeah Bishop g7 and this is not gonna
last
wool black almost flags he'd point
something seconds left flag flag flag he
flagged we won on board four versus
board once a theramin went down Wow I
had to be Internet or lag or something
that's insane
what a fight that's so awesome
Joshua group in ski rated below 2000 I
think his rating is actually higher now
but at least like earlier rating below
2000 Wow
so we won three games at that round
there's four rounds total four games per
round I feel bad for a sitting room on I
met him a few months ago in st. Louis
nice guy very strong player I mean it's
completely winning in the final position
he just like right king off six I mean
okay the king just runs like king of six
there's Knight g8 ke5 I'm sure there's
other ways to run to I was amazing nice
job Joshua I was about to just like look
at that like other stuff and not even
focus on this game but that got really
exciting so I'm gonna try and update the
score this is gonna be a challenge
because I think it might cover the
screen for a moment but let's actually
let me check with ya
okay so I'm pretty sure our board three
forfeited
which I'll try and get more information
when I have it but let me update the
texts yeah let's move this and it is
three to one in favor of the windmills
okay so yes I'm a member of the the
Webster windmills I think I'm I'm on the
roster as a player I'm not planning to
play any games this season unless I need
me but I am I'm a manager I'm basically
the social media manager so helping with
Twitter with live streaming on Twitch I
was a main manager for the last two
years but because I'm travelling so much
and I'm not living in st. Louis there
are some new managers now but yes I'm
still very much affiliated with the team
and I'm rooting for them as much as
possible so clearly rooting for them
helped at least in this game so I think
the next round is gonna start in a
couple minutes so I'll try and answer
some questions we have a question from
Neal Homer or Niall Homer it's annular
Niall no it's not look has opened file
writes how do you recommend getting out
of a slump in terms of chess playing
I've had a streak of losses and I feel
like I've got worse even though I've
been digging to reassess your chess
yeah chess is not like other things
where if you work you instantly get a
rewarded for it's usually the the
general path to improving in chess
involves short-term rating fluctuations
and by short-term rating fluctuations
those could kind of take place over
years but like long long term if you're
studying and you're staying staying
active and saying passionates usually
your your overall chest
understandings should be improving but
if you're if you're playing and you're
not seeing immediate results it's just a
matter of persistence I actually wrote a
bit about this I was in a slump for four
from four to five years where my rating
was just completely plateaued I felt
like I wasn't improving and then in the
span of like three months and two
tournaments I gained a hundred points so
rating doesn't correlate necessarily
with with chess ability the two are
related but like your reading could go
down but your understanding can go up
especially if you're studying something
new then it's actually common for your
rating to go down because you might be
experimenting with new things over time
just have to stay persistent it's my
best advice any recommendations for afor
openings that are similar in style to
London that's a difficult question
because I mean when you play e4 black
has so many different responses and you
have to react to each response usually a
bit differently so yeah it depends on
the the response from black and then
within each opening I can give
recommendations but you can't play it's
hard to play a generic efore opening
against every single black defence but I
have given recommendations in the past
Knight c3 Sicilian two knights attacking
ins French two Knights attack against
caro-kann a lot of these openings just
prioritize development and have some
tricky nature to them so now we have
round two starting
and this is still concerning because I'm
not seeing a report we have aboard three
oh he is playing wait a minute am I not
observing him okay closing out of some
games here how do I observe him sort of
game okay so let me explain what's going
on it's three two one and one of our
players Alex G Manav very strong
Grandmaster from Russia from what I
heard he's in Vegas right now and he was
struggling to find internets something
some issues with the hotel he was at so
what to do but now okay it looks like
he's online and he's playing against
Arthur Amman
we just had a very disappointing loss
again if I was a theremin right now I'd
be like completely on tilts flagging in
that position and that's the brutal
thing about this league is like if you
lose a game there's not too much
recovery period like you have to play a
game right away you have to play four
games in a row with very little break so
we have a caro-kann and probably what
I'll do I'll just take a quick round of
the games and then pick which one I
think will be the most interesting so
okay this is some dynamic middle game
some advanced variation limb lay against
Alex Katz this is very boring looking
for Knights we have our hero at least so
far of the match Joshua grim in ski
against very strong Grandmaster Oteri's
Agha I'm tempted just to stay on this
game some very dynamic kind of benoni
position maybe came from a Sicilian
and then we have nish Nick against John
Mueller
their board for well the opening was
this exchange Slav Bishop g5 I remember
having some study sessions at Webster
and the players just discussing this
variation I wasn't really paying
attention but I vaguely remember f6 as a
move and then stuff gets weird after
that the black just played some normal
stuff and then okay this is actually
similar to some chomp house key line
where Y takes early and has slightly
better structure and there's some
positional play my white house ideas of
Bishop g2 and Knight f4 as a deep on is
isolated so box going for b5 potentially
before and remove the knight from
attacking the the d5 pawn so my first
inclination would be to play Knight f4
and allow 92 but okay he's allowing b4
and I guess the question is where does a
knight want to go after b4 like you go
back to b1 or do you go to a4 or maybe
you have Queen a4
and again we see the speed of Ilya like
he's like Bishop g2 it's a move I would
take time on and calculate before but he
just allows me for and lets his opponent
think super major pain with a hundred
bits
thanks for the bits so I want to see
black play v4 because I'm curious what
Ilya is going to do in response
domination
thanks for the comment second time on my
stream you didn't say hi in the last one
I forgive you for that
yes John Bartholomew is playing in the
protest League I think he plays later on
today I think he's playing China I know
he plays dinger and like in the first
game it's gonna be an interesting battle
okay so before was played at night they
for and very quickly b3 and Illya just
blitz us out I take b3 like nothing
happened like how do you just take on me
three right away just such a surprising
move so it's somewhat of a positional
sacrifice Bach is now trying to win back
the pawn and the b3 pawn is a bit hard
to defend
I'm wondering if white just gives it
back maybe castles and I always feel
good when I guess they move the GM plays
yeah I just Castle if Knight takes b3
yes or Acosta move
Roque to stay on the a file and then
again like this pawn it's still isolated
still ideas of this in this and the
Nightline b3 it looks impressive but
it's really not doing too much Knight c3
is nice it comes with initiative
actually why it's gonna have some like
continual threats here because a seven
needs babysitting and then Knight f4
then the D pawn will need babysitting I
don't know if black has enough
babysitters I think the Queen has
potential to maybe defend but the
Queen's already defending d5 if d5 is
lost that's a key Center pawn so black
just gives up on defending a7 I love
white even wants to take a seven because
my thought for like why not just win d5
right away really liking the play by
ilya like his last game was great to
just like keeps applying pressure and
doing it quickly too so yeah let me
answer some more questions in the chat
the time control is 15 plus 2 so 2
second cream it's normally with
increment players shouldn't flag but we
did see it in the the previous round
their third one flagged against our
board for seven hundred point rating
differential
hello to more people I can't pronounce
her name
giddy something something something and
hello Tim doing well
we should have mods in the chat right
okay so d5 is lost yeah Knight takes d5
okay Bishop takes d5 Knight takes d5
great position for whites I think we're
gonna maybe move on to a different game
because when Illya gets to advantage
like his technique in converting winning
physicians is pretty stellar so let's
look at Joshua's game Joshua putting up
another fight
hey donation me make it bigger next
Coffee is on me says domination thank
you yeah actually two dollars can buy at
least two coffees in Thailand this so I
appreciate that and there's some good
coffee here too like there's so many
like different I don't know
foreign-looking options where they mix
even know but I appreciate the two bucks
yeah real quick let's just take a look
at the opening because I'm curious what
this came from symmetrical English okay
actually play this line as white with
III in g4 so early d5 these positions
can be difficult for lack because it
feels cramped like there's not much
space but there is a c5 square to work
with this might find some next post and
a5 is very thematic to stop before and
essentially reinforce the knight on c5
rookie aides sometimes rookie a the idea
is to meet Bishop h6 with Bishop h8
preserve the dark squared Bishop
ensuring that's Fe it's isn't our
targets Bishop a6 okay attacking see for
now e5 probably the other idea of the
key eight is just to push the e pawn
so lots of traits and look like white
had some pressure but somehow whoa okay
things got really messy like a fork and
then a pin and then defend against check
and then queens are getting traded wait
I thought white one upon there I loose
it did weights a cup on why can't I
count oh so okay so it's equal material
and then he won upon oh okay I wasn't
counting the kingside so white is up
upon in the current position but black
has two bishops so it's still a fight
like one thing about the two bishops is
sometimes you can choose when to trade
off the night and if black can play for
example Bishop g7 and Bishop takes on b5
then there's drawing chances then it
would just be off the clare bishops very
hard for a white to win so Bishop d7
would be my first inclination here
please King he 7 first I wonder was
there anything wrong with Bishop g7 King
g7 feels off because it puts the king on
the file of the rook usually you just
don't want because now Bishop g7 runs
into something like f4
okay so we'll let this game develop a
little bit
say hello to more people hello to Aiden
from Ireland's question from Arad 1 2
off-topic question what's my favorite
food or dish so since I was a little kid
my favorite food has always been pod tie
and today I had some of the best pod tie
I've ever had it was amazing
my Airbnb host recommended a song like
some random ball restaurant so I went
there and she said it's the best pod tie
in Thailand which means it's probably
the best pod tie in the world and I was
definitely the best pod tied I've ever
had it had like smaller noodles but it
just it had so much flavor and like
nicely presented so I'm definitely going
back there at least several times and
thanks for the bits heart wise a noodle
I'm trying to work on your name
welcome back have I ever had an over the
board game that was theory for you from
beginning to end from beginning to I've
had some very like deep theoretical
games like prepared for the first 20
moves from beginning to end
yes actually once at least once maybe
more I mean there's been like quick
miniatures I had like a 20 move game I
want to say it was a case six national
championships I was like in fifth grade
or fourth grade and I played a variation
my first coach taught me and like we had
a notebook where we kept all my chess
openings I was like one of the very
first variations I learned I was in the
notebook and it was just a whole game
like just 20 moves white sacrifices the
exchange
no white sacrifice is a whole rook and
like two or three pawns and then mate
and played out the full game maybe I'll
make a youtube video on that let me
write that down 18 move miniature a
molar attack ironically I'm writing this
down in a notebook
I bought a notebook today and for like
the first time in 5 years I was walking
through the mall came across this
bookstore and it said stationery I
figured that like notebooks are useful
some nice escape from the digital world
okay what's going on oh so I've I get
distracted then the position just strain
transforms drastically but blocks
counting two pawns I really didn't like
kini 7 because he had to go out of his
way to stop at 4 so he lost age 7 but ok
officer Carter bishops super major pain
is subbing so life isn't so bad and a
force plate so he's trying to simplify
it takes takes actually a4 is very nice
because if this line happens B takes a
Ford rook takes c4 this pawn can't
really be defending because the bishop
controls a1 and the rook controls C -
it's like Bishop c2 or rook a1 I'm just
unplayable and meanwhile black just
wants to take and if white plays Bishop
c2 then like a3 a2 could even be winning
actually maybe not maybe bishops he
choose playable and then there should be
one but that's not what white wants so
again there's it's amazing like Joshua
eager Minsky rated far below his
opponents
again putting up some some valiant
fights
take a glance at Ilias gain Ilias just
crushing no need to look at that so the
GM going in the tank I mean whether the
candidate moves for whites I yeah I'd be
sure he had to take and this is nice
because box position plays itself for a
few moves like just eat pawns and this
pawn is a potential strength if black
can get it rolling
it's a passed pawn it's only passed pawn
on the board now the thing about
obstacle are bishop positions is that
it's very easy to set up lock aids so
this probably won't be a threat but okay
more importantly the eight pawns
following a five it's a five do anything
a five takes B six the pawn can get to B
seven but then the rook comes behind and
this pawn starts rolling I would think
that this is what aterrizaje is
calculating it seems pretty concrete's
and then you have to like determine if
the rook can come in and tie in and
promote before the a plumber rushes down
the board Murray clay says the rook the
bricks look cool at first I was like
what bricks and I realize behind me yeah
for those who don't know this is my
second stream of today or of this
morning i streamed earlier this five
hour long term it's on me chests just to
stay awake for the protest League so I'm
trying to stay energized I still have a
little bit of tea left that's very
strong because I left the tea bagging
okay so we're seeing this line this is
gonna be exciting those whites going all
in I mean worst case scenario that can
push and then the bishop forever defends
b8
which is a nice resource to have
majesticness I'm not playing in the in
this
I'm only doing commentary I'm
technically part of the windmill team
but only four players play the match
rook III
okay so rookie threes prophylaxis
against plenty three so one move that
comes to mind is Bishop to b2 just
control a3 and get the pawn rollin
it's nice position to have time to
calculate a little bit plays Bishop d4
maybe now Oh now Bishop b2 there's rook
takes a four that's unfortunate
so Bishop a7 okay so things are a bit
stuck ooh that's a good move as pawns
gonna be lost and the ops of Corey
Bishop ending i think is just lost it's
really unfortunate
he's going for a counter play it but
don't think it's anything and White has
more than enough time and Bishop takes
f2 though I rotate would come
yeah I saw Carlson play I didn't see the
whole thing but I saw Carlson play a
little bit of the title green then I saw
the final result it was just insane he's
so good at chess I saw him play last
night too and uh I wasn't in any event
it was just some like bullet match
against this Iranian GM they played 71
games straight Black is pretty much dead
here unfortunately all the other games
are still going so yeah let's just make
sure that this one is actually finishing
because okay this is a check and if King
each one there's like per pet so he has
to move to h3
but why is white thinking here King a
tree's only move what oh Kim Ji Won is a
move well they're playing so quickly
like I would be taking time trying to
figure out this discovery scenario yeah
unfortunately I don't think there's any
good discoveries maybe g4 g4 and get
some perpetual
let's call you AG for Queens rook f3
that's just a draw
I think kingi - Rick f2 is if the King
moves to h1 is rook F 1 to G 1 with
mates
oh the problem with rook over the
problem of g4 is rook I fates ah almost
works rook a multi-purpose the reason
why white doesn't Queen immediately is
rook B to check so okay it supports be
AIT's friends Raqqah fades
if we see them move like I mean if we
see a move like rook f5 King G to rook F
to the King just runs to h3 yeah that's
kind of sad
mari shakhov asks where am I at
nice location I'm in Thailand in Chiang
Mai I only found out today the bricks
behind me they're just painted on the
wall they're not actual bricks like
they're just it's a flat wall they look
so realistic like it's good whoever
painted them was just genius but it does
add to the decor I found at least
spending some time in like Airbnb is in
Asia the interior design is really good
oh so he he allowed Regatta face okay
now it's over okay so I mean that was
expected results I mean one win from
Joshua is just stellar result for this
match so let's move on
Ilya won his game crashing final
position nice so let's look at the Kong
Leon's game they have some some major
piece and game with white having these
menacing Center pawns I'm just trying to
absorb what's going on here f6
disobeying the natural laws of been
feingold inviting a six six looks like a
nice invitation just push the pawn
because if you six if anything takes on
defy me just play e7 i think
maybe there's some Queen d6 check I'm
sure he's just trying to calculate
concretely it takes on f6 that's very
logical to those blacks King is gonna be
very unsafe there is Queen d6 check
Queen d6 pick up the pawn with the Queen
White's up a pawn here though
got your queen takes f6 White has extra
center pawn and a huge time advantage
so yeah I really like limbs chances and
most people on the Webster team call him
limb before I knew him I just called him
like Longley Emma
but yeah Lynn or Leon that says like go
to name so he loses a d5 pawn and leaves
a this pawn on the board it seems like
there's some nice forcing variations for
whites like okay the first line I
calculated this and then f7 but then
black is almost meeting maybe the line
could continue like Queenie a king h7 f7
rook d1 rook e1 trail anyone don't think
that seven pawn is making it
there's also this moved f7 right away
because if King takes f7 Queenie Yates
King f6 rook F - that looks really fun
King g5 or maybe rook at five workout
five that's frustrating because there's
no good checks trade rook so he takes on
g7 destroying all shelter that the black
king had thanks for the comment Bertie
be good to see you in the chats okay so
it's not back ring mates the King can't
take on g7 yet because there'd be queen
g4 check and if trade on e1 then white
is winning h4 in some lines so Queen d2
trying to force a trade Oh Queen G for
picking up the rook I was just simple
tactics well done
laQuan Liam two for two we have one game
left
so theramin against she moneth Shimano's
first scheme of the protest League of
2019 because he didn't show up for the
first game let's try and absorb what's
going on black is better up a pawn
amazing knight on f3 I like to call this
octopus so it has so many tentacles
eight to be exact
but White has counterplay like these
rooks and knights are a little bit scary
like there's some threat of this wait
can black just play rook d1 and me on g1
maybe Knight g5 hmm he has time to
calculate
there is also an ITX h4 look which looks
kind of interesting but probably doesn't
work super major paint asking if i went
to africa to give out the five thousand
fifty thousand dollars worth of chess
boards that you gave to me I have not
been to Africa yet I'm going next month
but I do have chess boards to give none
of which I was given I was given money
to buy chess boards though there is some
stream a couple of months ago where
people donated saying that I shouldn't
buy chess boards for kids in Africa so I
got two nice boards one is a I travel
magnetic set another one is like a
fold-up board kind of term in style
pieces I'm hoping to get some maybe
basic books but I mean they all speak
some obscure language so I don't know
when I'm I'm gonna stop in Portugal when
I'm there I'm gonna try and find some
basic chess books so he played ninety
one what does this mean Black has at
least in drama I feel like it's gonna be
a draw usually when he thinks like
things like this he's trying to find a
win he's probably not finding it he's
probably just going to take the pawn
give perpetual check and that will be
that
so Illya one if this is a draw than it's
two and a half to one and a half so we
win kind of the mini match and it is
going to be a draw by repetition so let
me update the score
Webster windmills move up to five and a
half five and a half two and a half my
do mouth let me change the score here
okay five point five two two point five
shifts over a little bit not that
be nice to have like a whole graphics
team to do this for me but okay there we
go looks decent so the next game should
start shortly it should start
automatically so let me say hi to more
people and the chats kb con thought i
was in some slum I'm not in any sort of
slum I'm in a relatively cheap apartment
but cheap and Southeast Asia is still
still be really nice
covert asking an interesting question
you like the video with Tam am i
planning to do more instructional videos
with students usually I don't record
private lessons only if the student
wants to to like save it for later
so it worked out with Tam but I did do a
lesson with a friend recently it was
just kind of a really casual lesson
where we just analyzed one of his games
but it was all recorded like
automatically on zoom so I'm trying to
get the recording from him and he was
more than happy to let me make sure a
clip of it for YouTube so maybe within
the next week I'll post another video
like that we kind of did a trade because
my friend is like pretty successful
youtuber has over 300,000 subscribers so
he was giving me advice on like YouTube
strategy I was giving him advice on
chess strategy so win-win for both of us
Manas Ahmad okay fifty thousand boards
no pieces I have pieces to my chessboard
had to make an appearance last string
because there is this giant moth and I
had to use it to protect myself any
handy tips for getting the most out of
chess books
I'm tired so it takes longer to think
about stuff I think okay the kind of an
easy tip is to rather than just read the
book is to set up the position over the
board you're looking it over the board
and physically interacting with the
pieces can help you internalize things
better especially compared to just
passively reading like the physical act
of making the moves I think it should
have some psychological impact of just
helping you better internalize things
another tip I have maybe a couple tips I
have another big one is find a training
partner find someone around your same
ability ideally in person so like go
over the book together another tip which
you can do actually this would help if
you don't have anyone in person to to
work on it with is to create ally chess
study I know we're on chess calm right
now but okay creatively chess study and
say what you're going through in Lolita
study and that then that way you can do
kind of your own analysis do your own
research
everything gets saved so you can review
things later you can analyze with
stockfish
opening explorer and you can collaborate
with people so if you find someone
online whose wants to go through the
same book I like have a Skype session
and and yeah or even have multiple
people so those would be my tips I think
the next game will start in about three
minutes like the games ended slightly
more quickly the surroundings because we
didn't have any like sort of marathon
game compared to round one
how come I didn't make the team
I'm pretty sure I'm on the team we can
check it out though more bits from
Norwich Rapp thanks Norwich wrap or is
it norwich swap or is it no it's norge
it's wrap okay appreciate the bits let
me go to protesting calm let me try
something new here I switch the window
and people should see this is a website
and if we go to menu players and search
for rosin hey it's me
so I'm them I'm officially a player in
the league I doubt that I'm gonna be
playing any games but if I'm needed I'll
show up I wonder if I could stream and
play at the same time
I'd be interesting you'll homer with
more bits saying thank you thank you for
what oh I answered your question you're
welcome
ok let's go back games should start next
minute so we only need let me try to do
math we only need 3 points to win the
match there are 16 points up for grabs
we have a donation 4 dollars from
majesticness it's so small and it's hard
to see hi Eric I'm a fan and it goes
away
feel free majesticness if you want to
share your comment in the chat or I'll
make a clip out of it or something but
thanks for the donation do you
appreciate it
so yeah usually the game start I like
any time divisible by 10 so it's 639
right now the Sun should be rising maybe
I'll see a sunrise but it's cloudy so
maybe not Zach - 1 5 etc you probably
got this question a lot but I just
started watching YouTube videos I'm very
interested in try and chess out any
basic things I should do tell me start
off there's so many resources online I
mean if you're already on YouTube that's
a great starts chest AHA Marley chests
maybe got a council on both sites you
can get a free account on chess calm
they have premium memberships - with
more features me chess everything is
free very easy to start playing people
if you're a complete beginner I
recommend going to me chest org slash
learn and going through the exercises
very user friendly builds up some just
basic pattern recognition and then like
once you complete all the exercises and
it gives you resources to go from there
but yeah I do what you enjoy like if you
enjoy watching videos watch videos if
you like to play then play when you're
first starting out the the chests
landscape can be overwhelming and things
can vary from Player to Player everyone
has their own learning style so if
you're looking to improve sometimes you
have to see what works and what doesn't
work so we have games starting
symmetrical English between Teresa and
Luc Longley M so we're getting to the
mat or the point in the match where the
pairings are leveling out and there's
some closer fights at least raiding lies
smaller rating differentials are bored
one is playing their board too
actually the most recent time I played
laQuan Liam in a tournament
I played the English against him and he
played he played symmetrical English I
think he played a different line he
started with night ah 6 before 96 and he
went for the media T 5 and he completely
outplayed me but I know he's very well
prepared he's minds
he's a former world rapid world rapid
world blitz oh you won the world blitz
championship in 2013 I was opening
preparations very strong positional
understanding very strong very good at
moving quickly he has not wasted any
time off his clock
I'm adjusting this interesting common
you're an entrepreneur making laser-cut
engravable chess sets Wow I don't know
if I can answer your question what to
engrave on it but you can send me a
message you can go to my website contact
form
yeah and bad with suggesting things to
engrave but that sounds really cool love
to learn more okay so they're developing
let's do the usual around and then we'll
pick which game is most interesting we
have wait did all the games start oh I
need to watch tema again I don't want to
do that where is she mom off
okay so hey we have a polar bear opening
I haven't seen the polar bear opening
since I played the polar bear or since I
attempted to play the polar bear f/4 I
moved one so the funny thing about this
opening I only discovered this or made
the realization like a day or two ago
but the polar bear opening starts out as
a birding earthwards of birds opening
I'm sure a lot of people watching have
already seen that I've posted a lot of
content around the bird like around the
what do I want to call it around chess
and birds recently
if there's anyone watching who hasn't
seen it you I don't know how you found
my stream without seeing the all the
content I post it on the bird but the
bird opening is 1/f for my most recent
Instagram picture is a picture of this
position with a bird sitting on f3 like
an actual bird and yeah very soon like
after e3 and b3 this is now the polar
bear so that's how evolution works the
bishop wants to come to b2 and white
just wants to dominate the e5 square
it's actually a really interesting
configuration relatively aggressive and
the nice line especially for a GM to
play against substantially lower rated
player there is I mean it's offbeats
black house to think from early on let's
go forward here because many more moves
have been played yeah so white is okay
giving away the bishop hair just to
strengthen control over a five because
95 is nice and now of a d3 with the plan
of 92 and 93 now it's thinking usually
it's nice if black castles King side
because then there's some potential
attack that the Queen combined with the
bishop I think black is being smart here
by holding off
and not castling Kaden Jay Taylor has
not seen the bird video you can just go
to my youtube channel if you type in
Eric Rosen bird into YouTube it should
be the first hit I would imagine unless
I'm completely wrong but it's yeah click
the link that moobot just shared thanks
- so he plays mighty - natural move
wants to go for the maneuver it's
getting light outside but there's no Sun
it's so foggy so depressing
looks like rush hour - major highway so
many cars
so this game could take some time to
develop so let's move on to the nimac
game playing a caracal oh yeah you
usually play this the French but I think
a lot of GM's on the Webster team are
very capable of playing Carroll Khan
it's from Nora's rap what am I gonna
become a Grandmaster a great question I
wish I knew the answer I don't really
have the active ambition of being a GM
because I think a lot of people don't
understand there's a big gap between
iron and GM so right now it's not a
priority for me but I do own GM
rosen.com just in case okay so some
caro-kann theory I feel like I've seen
this line before like Ilya is still
having most of his time on the clock
trying to make sense of this I mean the
pawn on e5 is weak this is kind of a
double-edged sword so in one hand it's
kind of a target but on the other hand a
control space it allows ninety-six in
some positions so with rook c1 white is
saying that black can't take the pawn
because the bishop is pinned
which is logical it's actually a little
bit annoying here for black rook ta
can't be playing this Bishop is here f6
doesn't want to be played the pawn on e5
h6 just Bishop h4 so what to do maybe
get the Queen out of the pin but Queen
c7 I mean you're walking into the the C
file
maybe just rook c8 Brooke CA there's one
of these those normal-looking improving
moves but I don't know if it does
anything because white has maybe some
plan of Queen is some eventual plan of
Queen b3 Rick do you on maybe even Queen
d2 Rick do you want and just apply a lot
of pressure because there was only to
open files in the position the CND file
and because especially because this
bishop controls d8 black might have a
hard time contesting the D file so
Norwich is wrapped to get the GN title I
would need 3 GM norms together GM norm
you have to play there's a lot of
requirements but you have to play in a
least a nine round tournament you have
to play at least three GM's in that
tournament and you would need a
performance rating of I think 2600 feet
a which is very difficult to do you also
need to play I think at least seven
title players and at least five
different countries represented among
your opponents so I've been close to GM
norms twice I was very close once where
I needed a win in the last round and I
drew but yeah I would need to spend just
full devotion maybe a few years just
focus and study and active play and a
lot more traveling to chase after the
title it's not worth it for me
how many times if I had a 2600
performance I mean I've had tournaments
for I'm undefeated where I mean arguably
it's over 2600 performance I think my
highest performance was like maybe mid
25 hundreds maybe high 25 hundredths my
best performance ever was
Chicago Open 2015 that was a tournament
if I had won my last round I would win
or I would get the GN norm and I would
win first place and $7,500 but I drew I
still won a couple of thousand dollars
and I got my my fourth I am norm but
yeah I could have been better
so okay so Ilya chose us h6g five idea
actually pretty logical I mean it looks
weakening but at least this rook is
happy and he pawns defended now by the
bishop but now released okay black is
solid it is 652 am in Thailand I'm going
to sleep after this match ends it's been
a long morning of streaming we have the
last game we haven't looked at Joshua
Griffin ski against Alexander cast let's
take a quick look at the opening and
then then I'll choose which game to stay
on d6 97 we call this the old Indian and
transposes into some Philidor yeah all
of this is very natural 9 g5 interesting
night g5 kind of both sides lost Tempe
that's why it had to move back and forth
black had to spend time moving the rook
I like the way Joshua was playing
keeping his composure having some space
advantage on the Queen side
I mean he's playing again significantly
higher rated player but keeping his cool
staying reasonably close on the clock
and that's a good sign because this is
his first time playing in the protest
League for our team and I know it can be
intimidating playing alongside three
like grandmasters and playing against
grandmasters in this case international
master he's one out of two for today
did he just blunder just as I'm praising
him I don't think he blundered too badly
in Queen g6 maybe was overlooked Black
has now two threats of taking on g2 and
taking on h3 I think white has to take
here and play 91 that's the only defense
I see maybe there's not h4 though so
okay if tonight takes off for Y can
decide between these two moves
now actually if I can just okay make
sure you're not losing anything on the
kingside then focus on just positional
play like whites dominating the D file
my H was nice being active attacking the
Queen defending both pawns and also
maybe uh allowing some future and not
have five possibilities I have a feeling
White's slightly better here like very
impressive play have to check his actual
rating because I know he's not 1979 I
think he's at least he's at least 2,200
US rated maybe his fee their rating is
low sometimes use Scholastic kids from
the US like they just don't play feed a
rated events so they're very underrated
and very valuable when it comes to
approach s League Queen g3 I like trade
Queen's keep it positional even though
white is allowing kind of the damage
structure the pawn on g3 chases this
night away the night would then be
restricted by like white spawns from all
sides and then the knight can come to f5
I why he just wants to keep making life
better
rook d7 eventually nine of five
eventually so we're gonna see this very
positional endgame maybe Bach has
something to fight for as okay e4 is
kind of isolated are some ideas of
Knight g5 maybe we'll see King f2 to e3
like why not centralize the king rook t7
first okay attack the pawn
I would expect b6
then there's some follow-up ideas like
not have 596 fb6 like to play a six and
then the a pawn is just fixed there's
also a move for black rook d8 I mean the
great thing for white though okay he's
expected to lose this game being out
rated so if black simplify is okay
that's fine but if black tries to keep
things on the board to play for a win it
could be risky so I kind of forgot about
the chat I'm talking about performance
rating is really good thanks for the
comment was that emo still theory emotes
over saying team burger bin ski yeah he
should just change our team name the
Webster Corbin skis we have two of them
Aaron gourbin ski is is he an I am no I
think he's I am elect or at least close
to I am
and we're gonna see knife at five how
many people have their knife at five
emotes the opening was weird it was d6
97 very quick slow motion replay d6 97
and it was some old Indian I played
through it earlier I wasn't the most
like exciting opening but like whites
just keeping some pole
okay so we did CB six a six I mean if I
were a white just improve the King first
does black want to play King he eats and
maybe King he aids if rookie seven King
goes back whoa
so some trade wait a minute can the
knight to hop into c8 and win the pawn
or even win this pawn it's happening
because this night is so clumsy
okay maybe c5 is possible but c5 Knight
see it's still a knight c6 there's b5 so
what happens after a night c8 the night
c7 but there's a line maybe it doesn't
work but maybe it works 9c 897 Knight
takes a seven-night takes a 6 and then
Knight takes on c6 and White's up a pawn
he doesn't go for it
ah he's going for b5 it's astounding how
quickly he's playing because like I feel
like there's so many lines to calculates
and I don't know he's if he's playing on
intuition or if he's just calculating at
ridiculous speeds I think the the first
round there is the game between Nick and
cats
I was also some night ending where cats
just got completely outplayed so we
might be seeing it again and b5 makes a
lot of a lot of sense just hold on to
the strongest pawn in the position
if night's c7 so problem with night c7
b5 is that whites tied down to defending
97 b5 and then the thread is keen e7 my
problem is I'm just so tired to
calculate precisely much rather just sit
back and watch what happens
casual mate in 24 says I like that name
by the way
have I seen the site about the elo meter
and do I believe it's accurate it was
accurate for me I did a whole video on
it if you type in my name and alone
either into YouTube you can see me
struggle for two hours trying to
complete the test but it was in like
within 15 to 20 points I think of my
actual rating but then you read the the
YouTube comments and people are are
getting results that are missing by
hundreds of points I think it's lesser
or less accurate for lower rate of
players but yeah it's sometimes hard to
say with those types of models lucky
Luke thanks for the comment
there's something wrong with the UI this
the bottom board oh that's not a UI
comment wait what did fate say
too hard to keep track of the chats
this is bored for for the windmills our
top three boards are 2600 + GM's our top
board is 2700 + all games still going
I'm not going to switch them because I
I'm very curious how this position is
going to unravel but I'm just taking a
glance slim layers up upon
FEMA has Oshima's getting I don't know
what's going on in chimas game and Ilya
Ilya is getting crushed okay
or is he sometimes it's hard to judge
limb is better Ilias worse Shema unclear
hello to McDonald from Brazil what time
is it in Brazil infinite flash chest
says my setup is great you were
referring to what fate was talking to
okay yeah sometimes it's weird I'll read
comments and people are talking to each
other and not to me then I got confused
real quick I want to just glance at
Shima's game because I'm so I'm also
just really confused about this position
oh he's just crushing he's whites some
reason I thought he was black
he's yeah he's just monster crushing Wow
okay we saw the the bird turned into the
polar bear turn into a massive King side
attack like how does black allowed
Bishop takes f6 because now we see this
rook lifts like all these moves are so
common for this structure f5 nice like
black castle and I was trying to on
castle Queen g5 nice move c4 is really
nice too trying to remove the spawn to
allow 94-94 is just going to be
devastating feel so good when all of
your pieces are just attacking and
coordinated and f6 is of targets if the
Queen moves to the fens there's rook
takes a fate followed by Queen takes h6
and black is below a minute okay life is
good for Shima and he's in Vegas okay so
we have some developments in in this
game we'll stay with this one okay so we
saw C 497 b5 so this is what I was
trying to calculate but it was too tired
to do so and now ah so now there's this
interesting barrier the King can't enter
the center King he hates illegal and
King e7 walks in tonight's CA takes a7
defending b5 nice little Knight dance so
black plays g6 trying to maybe activate
the King like this now that's a question
what does white do and white is thinking
so even though this plan takes three
moves I don't know if White has anything
useful to do in three moves like the
night is tied down to be five white
could actually be worse here
unfortunately because if the King comes
to e6 and then you have to move the
knight you lose the b5 on
so he's activating the King that's not
good to play King F to run into King g7
and start thinking again he's gonna
fight even if he loses a pawn but okay
so ah so he attacks a5 and he wants to
go to a3 nice and then if his King can
come to like c4 then his knight can be
free to roam the board so 93 nice way to
save the pawn I still have a feeling
black is better though
the white had to maneuver the night from
d6 to a3 it's not a good sign wow it's
really foggy as people see this look at
that fog it's so foggy
huh there is a tropical storm that hit
Thailand but didn't really hit my area
directly but we got some rain so this
might be like some consequence from it
speaking of consequences Oh King see if
I've looked scary but night-night see
for a nice move and blocks under a
little bit of time pressure
so clearly okay white just wants to hold
on play for a drama I don't think this
is pollution if it's pollution that's
not a good sign I think it's just miss
chief okay so a 5 g 4 I'm imagining like
Nathan just cheering saying play G for
now
and Joshua giving and happened to me
last stream okay so King takes e4 easy
move the problem for white is that 3 on
2 because these pawns are double well I
can't really make a pass pawn and black
has a passed pawn I'm trying to figure
out like 94-96
takes takes I think the King pawn ending
is winning 4 back it should be easy win
for black
and that's not good if the night can
start crawling all over the place
okay so she mana officially one night
okay night see for allowing the King
upon ending not so sure about this 96 it
should just be for the reason that yeah
blocks just gonna walk up and eventually
these cones will be interlocked I'll
watch it cuz sometimes I'm wrong but I
think I'm right this block can just keep
wasting Tempe with King e6 King g6
I mean he might be calculating like a
pawn race could also maybe be winning 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
not winning the useful trick to
calculate pawn races is to just
calculate the number of moves or count
the number of moves just remember who
moves first so he probably wants to play
H 5 H 5 seems like the best try and then
go for this but
what's going on in that line
can black with that
too tired to calculate the stuff
because it's a pawn on the h-file
against the queen pawns on each seven
maybe the Queen can sack and black wins
b5 and it's another pawn race I would be
insane I mean this is the only thing
white can go for it so we're gonna
probably see this play out he got 5 king
d5 because what else to do ah
the problem is blacks just gonna win b5
trade Queens and then winter at the
b-pawn it's unfortunate so he's trying
so yeah the the winning plan for lack
like just check King g8 check King here
and then take on b5 and then when white
Queens block trades Queens and then
promotes the b-pawn before white can
take the Jeep lot in her modes and he
sees it
oh there's also King e6 easy move to
like in this position King e6 and then
if Queen then Queen f7 mates much easier
I don't know why he's thinking his
multiple ways to win okay so he sees
this line that's the first line I saw
there's a funny trick if flocks King was
on e6 I would play King g6
hoping black would pre move Queen takes
h8 that would be stalemate but because
blacks King is on d5 there's no hope for
that yeah hard-fought game I think white
was better and then he just didn't he
didn't rely on concrete calculation
going back to this moment like okay this
is easy for me to say in hindsight but I
think it's an important lesson in the
position like this you should really
only trade rooks if you know you're
gonna win this a 7 pawn and I think he
maybe moved a little too quickly or just
in ZBOX resources with 97 and probably
could have held on to more clear
advantage earlier yeah I should have
kept should have kept rooks on the board
and then of course should have kept
Knights in the board but I think once 96
was played it was already pretty bad so
ooh
Lindley lost how did he lose I thought
he was winning
oh he was black
ah so yeah the names are weird cuz I
guess people don't see this song on the
stream but the names are off to the side
and the bottom name is black okay it's
strange so he lost so ilya is still
playing let's look at this game Ilias up
a bishop oh this is just completely
winning and he's up on time and he has
some meeting ideas and he's really fast
so should not have to worry about
flagging
which team am I on I'm on Webster
windmills and I found out earlier I'm
officially on Webster windmills I am on
the player roster I'm probably not gonna
play this this season and then be doing
a lot more commentary far less stressful
and more rewarding
speaking of rewarding thanks for the sub
Ryan Hartman is great
okay I won't argue with that
good job Ilya okay so we split the match
or at least a mini match two to two
Ilya won and Shimano one Joshua and
laQuan Liam lost so current score is
seven a half four and a half let me
update
7.5 to 4.5 wait till I do math correctly
that should add up to 12
yes okay Lana's saying get priyadarshan
back to Webster no production
grandmaster who graduated from watts
chair has moved to India and he switched
teams he played for the windows last
year he was one of our main managers
last two years but now he is playing for
one of the Indian teams so it's
unfortunate but that's life we still
have a number of GM's I could show our
roster just to show off some big names
let's go to teams windmills and I'll fix
try and fix that of the framing and the
moment okay so people o people can see
pictures too that's nice
so a iliyan is Nick he's a small person
but he's just monster at chess
laQuan Liam from Vietnam top top 40 in
the world she Manav
he's frightening on and off the board
Talia rising junior Peter from hungry
Emilio cordova new player recent recruit
from recent recruits of the Webster
University 18 and the Webster windmills
and here's our player roster so we can
see a plethora of GM's ray Robson should
be a common household name for people
from the USA and just any chess player
in general member of the US Olympiad
team that won gold the Seif Tara Bailey
so most of these almost all of these
players play for the webserie diversity
team or have played in the past
there I am towards the bottom the way
these matches work is that the four
players have to average below 2,500
feeding so you need some lower rate of
players to help balance out the high
grade players that's why we have Joshua
down here very good at balancing out
twenty six hundreds so the 1979 come
combined with Lim Ilya and she Manav
I think average is like 2485 she's a
pretty good number so anyway let's go
back to live chess I'll be streaming one
more round it's the final round games
should start in two minutes and then the
stream should be over in half hour
hopefully better be as I need sleep I'm
running out of voice and words I'm gonna
be right back and get some water good
time to take a break
so games should start in one minute if
people want more information about the
protesting you can visit protest league
dot-com and their websites pretty nice
well designed easy to find what you're
looking for
kudos to the web designers so we have
some people from Spain and the chats
good to see wait did laQuan Liam win in
San Francisco I know he lost a
Christopher you but I didn't see the
final results nice comeback if he did
I'll take passed pawns 99s word for it
have to look up the final cross table so
we have game starting speaking of limb
so final Matt our final games board one
plays board one board two plays board
two and so on
so it's kind of the the fairest matchups
and we have some bishops opening don't
see the bishops opening too often at the
highest levels ninety-two players
playing very quickly it seems like some
opening preparation sometimes there's
more leeway especially for high-level
GM's and Blitzer rapid chests to just be
more creative in the opening especially
if you're well prepared try and at least
got your opponent out of their comfort
zone early
so I am making some concoction of water
and vitamin C
don't want to spill this on my laptop
looks good this is a pro tip for people
who travel a lot or play a lot of chess
tournaments vitamin C supplements they
prevent you from getting sick very easy
to get any like drug school drug store
or like convenience store or
supermarkets good to take once in a
while okay so players are beginning to
think it's actually concerning that Lynn
is thinking first as he played the what
was supposed to be some surprise opening
I mean I should mention we only need one
points out of these four games to win
the match so hopefully that's not too
difficult there looks like there there's
a game that hasn't started which is a
little bit concerning oh wait no it's
Shima its Shimano scheme which has
started just wasn't following him here's
a game opening is this hey it's bits
it's from Mao Zedong epr that's a new
name thanks Mouse a Don didn't think I
would ever say those words in my life
but I appreciate the bits
okay so what opening is this Italian Oh
early D for actually I've had like
similar positions before I have never
known what to do against e4 but I guess
black sax
it doesn't really sack the pawn his
trade spawns hmm looks playable I mean
I'd be a little bit concerned about this
night but maybe it's okay me Ricky one
can't be played because f2 falls Queen
d5 scary-looking move but okay
worst-case scenario the knight can come
to e6
okay let's see the other openings at
least eugenic or other middle games this
looks like a London it's a London the
first London of the protesting and black
is employing the double Fein Canada
which is a solid response anyone who
doesn't know what to play against in
London this is actually kind of annoying
to play against it's just very sad for
luck
at least so positional game thanks still
very playable for both sides
a4 is very typical discourage b5 Queen
b3 very typical ideas of night C for
targeting b6 I've noodles with 500 bits
thanks for the bits saying enjoy your
stream a bunch Cheers
well I hope you enjoy your noodles and
now zedong has been watching YouTube but
it hasn't caught a stream until now so
yeah this is yeah this is basically
Kings Indian verses in London both sides
kind of have done their setups no side
has moved into the other's territory yet
so it's kind of a one of the the clues
of what will be a slow kind of
maneuvering game let's move on wait
there's sound happening but oh he took
the plot ok let's take a look at Griffin
skis game so this looks like some
nimzo-indian with g5 this is another
Nathan moment like sometimes when I play
and Nathan F is watching on twitch he'll
just say oh he'll cheer us some bits and
say play g5 now or play g4 now like g5
looks so random
like why weaken yourself oh he wants to
win the D pawn I guess
let's go back how did this develop yeah
so this is um this is a line I used to
study and then I I just stopped looking
into it I chose a more intuitive line
cuz it feels weird to put the Bishop on
e5 it feels like it should get trapped
but the pollen see if I have always
prevents before and at 96 is a weird
move I think it's very standard for this
position control c5 discouraged before
as looks so weird like all these black
pieces just on the Queen side and then
g5 I feel like g5 should be a move
that's still preparation okay so is
black winning upon you take on d5 right
so take sticks
problem is the Queen defends in the end
in so many lines a bit yeah a bit fishy
or a bit flashy not sure how to
characterize g5 it could be dubious it
could be interesting it depends on the
result of this game I have black wins
and g5s brilliant if black loses it's
probably the key mistake
but yeah it's a weird situation because
I don't think he can win the pawn right
away and he really doesn't want to take
on c3 they taking on c3 is through the
cycle those the dark squares are just so
weak because he played g5 Bishop is
pinda though
not sure that's referring to so it's
blacks move I mean white has some
resources coming up maybe Queen f3 one
move I would consider is Knight c7 just
increase attackers the knight is
defended on f6 by the Queen and I don't
think white is in a spot where efore can
be played maybe I'm wrong but I give a 4
then maybe then Bishop takes c3 Knight
takes e4 and White's king could be a
target too
hey I don't really like this approach
because black is on one needing to take
a lot of time and energy figuring figure
out what to do early on okay so he takes
on each five maybe queen ah six next
in Korea Essex has some idea of just
like trading Queens get some more
positional game so I'd be scared very
soon like h4 and just things opening up
oh wait I was looking at some of other
games I glanced over the game which I
thought was another game but it's just
the same game whites perspective with
the pawn on g5 yeah this is definitely
the most interesting game so I think
we'll stick on this one
we should keep in mind this player Yan
Muller has lost all his games so far
wait right we forfeited the first game
but you play the he played Lim in the
first round so yeah he's zero out of
three which I've been in the spot before
too it's not the most motivating kind of
situation to be in to play chess but
he's basically in a must-win situation
for his team and his position looks good
I this should take c3 this is a move I
said earlier it was probably just
suicidal I mean white still can't take
on d5 his own eye things yeah I really
don't like Bishop takes c3 nothing again
okay
Joshua has already done this job like
taking down the top player in the first
round so anything after that is icing on
the cake
but this is certainly not icing this
could be over very soon
f5 I guess idea of f5 is to meet h4 with
g4 her also to obstruct the bishop like
Bishop t3 there's no mate threats
oh man when you have to play a move like
f5 actually maybe it's it's still
logical I guess white is staying alive
if H 4g4 if Queen h6 probably just Queen
e7 or work f7
just terrifying like these dark squares
the King is running out of shelter I
think this is where black kind of wishes
a bishop was still on a five and the
night was still on e4 around on c3 was
black
what if white plays g3 h4 g3 would hang
the rook that would be nice
d6 this is insane move because it just
has a simple threat and I don't know if
that can stop it also prevents night c7
I think we're getting to the point where
we can safely call g5 a critical mistake
could have been brilliant
something happened in Black's favor yeah
the night is out of play like there's no
way to stop a gypsy for and the King has
nowhere to run or hide
I think Bishop c4 is made into b5 now
the one thing we have seen is okay
Joshua is a fighter he's gonna fight I
don't know what the idea is but okay if
Bishop takes b5 the threat is still
present okay so he's sacking the Knights
ah maybe I'll play Queen b6 no Queen B
the Queen's tied down to g5 it's painful
to watch
okay thankfully the other games still
very much underway and this is a team
competition so like one individual game
these things happen happened to me many
times I like the fact he's still
fighting despite to down a piece we king
but I can play Queen f6 then g4 I mean
early I was thinking Queen ah six but f6
is off-limits because of the bishop
unfortunately bishops are so powerful
especially in Paris
tall rule 73 good question I think the
plan will be to stay to keep the
commentary on my twitch just because
there's a built-in audience we do have
the web store windows twitch accounts
which should be although hosting me but
right now I don't think there's much of
a reason or incentive to stream from
other accounts but we do have access
which in the future if someone else
takes over comment here in the future
who doesn't have a channel then we can
use that channel
okay I feel like we should switch games
because we're not gonna get the one
point that we need in this game yeah
let's switch limb lay our top layer
against this paramount
Sousa Thurmond I'm trying to remember
how he did in round two and three cuz he
lost to it lost in round one I'm
forgetting I could go to his profile
shouldn't be too hard
Thanks okay so he oh he has not won a
game yet he drew shimano and lost to
Illya
so he's been having a rough day and now
he's playing for a former world blitz
champion laQuan Liam and actually seems
to have a difficult position like we saw
the opening earlier why playing this
bishops opening with 92 something I've
never seen before I think one of the
points is that white preserves f4 but
allows d5
it seems like some sort of reverse
scotch oh it has a little bit less space
the position looks relatively the equal
around here but now we see f4 which is
probably one of the reasons for this
like earlier king h1 their life
eventually does want to break with upon
open that file I'm liking the the
coordination like why does finding some
nice communication between the pieces
initiating some attack the knight was
attacked
so f6 was played rook lifts over g5 Wow
so we see g5 the second time in this
round from black maybe necessary in this
case defending along the seventh rank he
didn't want to play h6 I guess but white
literally has all the pieces on the
Kings side it's a lot of attackers so
Bishop trades off wait did you just get
fort
like when I highlight that this looks so
impressive but after a night afford
that's a fork and he's thinking here
that's not a good sign that's really not
a good sign
you'd imagine a super GM would see this
was Fork threats and that was a threat
when black played Knight g6 chest comm
was about to log me off I just say yes
I'm here
I mean okay you can sack on f4 maybe
when the pawn back and try and exploit
the king but what else is he considering
moving the Queen and what are the
candidate moves here oh maybe not have
six check what's going on in that
variation a fork g6 we take the knight
if king f7 there's Rick h7 so why does
nine s6 just right 906 oath things could
get complicated
alright the King moves we just take h7
maybe he's just making sure like maybe
it's winning and he's just making sure
it's winning as I don't see what block
does after this I have six rook takes f6
Queen takes g5 hitting the rook rook g6
and then we just take on that four
yeah Queen takes h7 loses material
unfortunately but if people can tell me
if I missing anything with 9f six
because this looks really good for a
white rook song hello I'm not in Bangkok
yet I'll be in Bangkok at some points I
haven't booked my flights to Bangkok but
I booked my flight out of Bangkok so I
have to be there at some point
what is Queen f3 I'm so confused about
this game like Knight takes f6 seemed so
logical and forcing I mean I'm
sleep-deprived so maybe I'm just missing
something obvious Queen a3 I guess the
point is to like somehow pin the Knights
and then if Knight takes h3 we can take
so yeah when I said that white got
forked earlier it was not one of these
like Elementary forks there's some very
deep underlying tactical variations
which are difficult for even like strong
GMS to calculates we can see you okay
white is low on time usually he has a
time advantage
yeah so Joshua is still playing but he's
getting mated early uh really appears to
be what's going on in this game
Ashima looks to be much better we'll
stay on this game I don't like to switch
too much is the position still
fascinating I don't even know what to
calculate here
I guess if black wants to he could
defend f6 and play some move like King
g7 and then the rock has to move so
maybe that's one potential variation
thanks for the comment Digital seven one
seven
really gonna have to go back and look at
this knight takes f6 move
because Queen Diggs g5 could be playable
well okay so if King g7 rook g3 then
White has some threats
maybe White's still having pressure here
I'm imagining whatever black does if
it's not Knight takes h3 then white will
go for rook g3 and h4 and just try and
undermine black setup so he takes on
each three takes on f6 now this is
hanging and I was gonna say a is also
hanging Wow so they're getting into some
Queen ending I think he has to or he
doesn't have to take the knight he could
throw in some checks
really not sure how to evaluate this I
think lights better light should be
playing for the win because this King is
a bit more or loose and if Queen takes
h3 white can start delivering checks at
the very least there should be some
perpetual maybe start with Queen I fades
material is equal
okay so Joshua officially Lost's Ilya is
still playing and she Manav still
playing real quick
she Manav has two rooks for Brooke
Knight and Bishop it looks like he's
winning a minor piece though at fish of
g5 h6 and that could just be match over
what how did this happen oh he got two
rooks on the seventh Bishop f6 hoping
for this fork but now we see a white
being clever now I kind of want to stay
on this game we might just see a
perpetual repetition no like at the very
least black intake and play the rook
ending up a pawn but we might see white
hold a draw the laQuan Leone game just
ended in perpetual white had nothing
just to show how this ended really have
to go back and look at 9:06 so current
match score is 8 to 5 we need half a
point
wait no the score is off or is it
oh no it's 8 to 6 so we need 1 point in
the next or half a point in the two
remaining games I'm pretty sure we've
clinched the match because Shima is not
losing this position I'll update the
match scored briefly 8 to 6 because
Joshua lost and Lim drew you centralize
the texts
[Music]
okay Wow g5g fives them the move of the
round three games so far black has
played g5 did Ilias games did black play
g5 with no way black played g5 every
single game black played g5 I guess in
some cases it's okay let's go back to
this other game
wait g5 wait g5 looks like a brilliant
move here and you just remove the
defender of the night or the the knight
is a defender you remove it you win the
g2 pawn and like usually in the middle
game two minor pieces are better than
two rooks but in endgame the rooks come
alive especially like this on the
seventh rank around the second drink so
he has a rook in two ponds for the two
minors
it still takes effort to win you
actually both pawns are hanging probably
King g6 is best King g6 or can't take
because mates and then like if black
plays King g6 and/or King e6 even the
b-pawn can start rolling King e6 is nice
attack the bishop the bishop has to stay
defending h2 looks like ilya is about to
win waitjust h5h 593 attacking the rook
I mean white is very low on time
he's just like rook' too
because the bishops still attacked the
bishop has to stay along this diagonal
expecting like rook a to Bishop b8 and
then be five those White's a bit stuck
hey Illya one nice final position
yeah like up a queen for not enough so a
final game the windmills have officially
won the match 9 to 6
I think the format this season every
point matters so if we win 10 to 6 we
get like 10 points total for the match
score and then 10 extra points for
winning the match
okay so we see the bishop retreating -
whoa we see everything retreating
retreats retreats Bishop t2 interesting
little cutting off the attack of the
rooks the one thing black doesn't want
to do is like take on d2 and simplify
into drawing rook engine so he has to
find some way to like keep things
interesting I like g4 maybe wanting to
go for each three but he does lose b7
White has six seconds left he should win
this somehow I don't know how but kg3
interesting egg whites about to flag
take on g3 nice
the threat is g2 let's fork so Rick g6
yeah
now this could be a draw like if white
wins upon maybe rook rook f2 there's
King g1 Wow somehow White's surviving
this I hope she even knows the score he
doesn't have to go crazy actually it
doesn't matter what he does there ring
gelt Jay I'm still abroad I'm in
Thailand Chiang Mai I'll be in the US
next month later next month next round
one g v g5 like g5 or g4 is one of the
worst first moves you can play in chess
yeah we're simplifying
Wow
so Shima did not win that but windows
won the match his final score of can I
do math nine point five to six point
five I think I did the math correctly
nice start to the season Miami strong
team but windmills prove their dominance
it would have been interesting if the
first round game with Joshua and so
theramin decided the match
where are our board for rated sub 2000
flags at 2650 g am in a completely
losing position but even if Joshua lost
that game we would still win the match
okay so that was fun hope people enjoy
that I think there's a match next week I
actually don't know the exact schedule
but people can find information on
protesting calm I'll be doing my regular
streams too I'll be doing more streams
coming up with playing viewers playing
more tournaments maybe doing some Q&A is
if people have feedback let me know I'm
working on putting together a stream
schedule which should be on my website
shortly week 2
so next week the game will be what to
fish in our VN okay we're in Atlantic
oh and six days six days no this is
Pacific time so seven days oh we're
playing the archbishop's okay you don't
want to miss next week we're playing
Fabiano car Wanda's team and Leslie sews
team crosstown rivals st. Louis versus
Webster which is still basically st.
Louis I didn't know that was taking
place next week I'll still be in
Thailand during that time should have
good internet planning the stream it's
stay tuned for that
yeah I'm taking off I would encourage
people if you want to see more
protesting chess you can watch
and chess comm I think they better be
streaming this chess calm / TV I'm gonna
raid them so if people want to join the
raid just stay around and then it should
automatically transfer you to their
channel so have a good day people and
I'll see you guys in the future